classic car ownership is one of these
things that is not just personal
it is actually incredibly extroverted
when you own a classic car you can own
it for your own personal reasons and how
you feel in that vehicle
but countless times you're driving one
of these cars you pull up to a stop sign
somebody shouts i had one of these back
in 1973 and i loved it so much
so there's this huge spike in the
classic car market as a result of that a
lot more people are turning their
classic cars into electric vehicles
these are fickle finicky vehicles
but when it's run by a massive battery
and electric motor it's basically as
reliable as a microwave oven
to do it elegantly is really an art it's
really about the love and the
appreciation of this art form and the
ability to own it and drive it as
trouble-free and as seamlessly as
possible that's what we're about
i'm mark davis
i'm the founder of moment motor company
here in austin texas and what we do is
we transform vintage cars into electric
vehicles
i've been obsessed with cars uh since
birth
[Music]
i'd love them in a way that seems
unnatural
[Music]
you know at this point we've done over
20 different chassis and we've applied
our technology to
lots and lots of different types of
vehicles front wheel drive rear wheel
drive
all-wheel drive trucks sports cars
sedans you name it
classic car ownership
for
as much enjoyment as you get from
driving the car
there's this constant
dread that you have you know under the
surface thinking about what's likely to
go wrong as you're driving that car you
can smell things you might hear
something
and it just is an endless kind of
undercurrent of worry
we have owners that come to us they want
the seamlessness of just not worrying
and just driving
[Music]
that's what the electrification does
we have other clients who come to us and
they they want the ability to appreciate
that art form but they want to do it
with a sense that they're doing
something with less impact to our planet
[Music]
so the first step when a client comes to
us with a particular car really what
we're trying to do is assure that this
is going to be feasible i don't want to
be responsible for tearing down a client
car and finding out that we really just
don't have a good solution we really
like to go
and look at every aspect of that vehicle
really what we can do is start
looking at the components that we know
work
blocking out a solution in our minds
that we think will be a reasonable
approach to electrifying here's what
we've got
once we've got a plan we start tearing
it apart
[Music]
really all we are doing is we're pulling
out the combustion drivetrain engine the
transmission fuel system things like
that we're doing that as carefully and
meticulously as possible
[Music]
our goal is to not hack this up our
motto is first do no harm right you
really don't want to dive into one of
these beautiful classics with a grinder
and a cut-off wheel and
slice it all up and do horrible things
to it the next step that starts with a
3d scan the first step in that is to put
down
locating dots all over so the scanner
can know exactly where it is in 3d space
the next step is to get the engine bay
the trunk the underbody scanned so that
we can bring it into our cad application
and start designing the parts that we
need to install the drivetrain
[Music]
once we have the car scanned we're able
to take these battery boxes motors and
our motor mounting systems and drop them
into the car virtually
then go through the painstaking task of
custom designing and engineering the
brackets the platforms the mounts that
will put these components into that
specific chassis
these are not modern electric vehicles
with a skateboard of batteries
underneath them and so we don't have the
luxury of tearing the floor out and
replacing it with a big
battery pack we have to put them in the
places in the car that that are now
empty which are typically the engine bay
in the trunk
we send those designs out to the laser
cutters the water jetters the machine
shops who will then
send us the results and we'll be able to
bring them back into the shop and test
fit them on the car
very quickly we arrive at a final design
and a final set of components that we
can
weld
finish
send off for powder coat and paint and
then it will come back to us for
installation
so in 2021 in the u.s at auction that's
online and in-person auctions 36 000
classic cars were bought in the u.s and
that's a huge increase
even over you know pretty high
pre-pandemic levels so it's about 56
increase over 2019 and that represents
2.2 billion in transactions and that's
an even larger increase so these cars
are going for even more money
that's just auctions the peer-to-peer
market which
people selling their cars to each other
on craigslist facebook and any number of
platforms like that is about 10 times
bigger so it's it's really a vital and
liquid market and it's booming at the
moment
electrifying classic cars
it is a controversial thing i mean
the people that that do this are told
all the time that they are taking the
soul out of a car and that
the sound and the smell is a huge part
of the experience and
there may be some truth to that for some
people
but if they're not getting out to drive
the car
because they're not sure it'll start
that's valid on the other side of the
argument too
it's an act of preservation
it started about a decade ago just with
people who decided to electrify their
cherished classic and some of those
hobby projects turned into businesses
it's a really
interesting skunk works required to kind
of make one of these shops work and
that's one of the reasons why there's
not a ton of them
[Music]
i like to describe myself as a wayward
engineer i
went to engineering school and went to
work in the software industry and uh
spent a long time in the technology
industry
the whole way though
i did what we're told to do which is do
the thing that you're good at to make
the money
so that you can do the thing that you
love
on the weekends on the side and i did
that and i followed the money
and i finally just
couldn't take it anymore
i was sick of hot rodding my cars in my
garage in a couple hours in the evening
after my kids went to bed
i really i wanted to do something that i
loved something i could be passionate
about
i think the opportunity of electrifying
classic cars kind of presented itself as
a unique combination of
the things that i was good at and the
things that i
loved so i could apply technology to
something it was not just a piece of
software for a customer
so that opportunity was something that i
i took i made the leap and i started the
company and here we are
once we've designed and test fit all of
these brackets and components then the
process is really taking these finished
parts and installing everything in the
car
if you look at an electric motor it's
typically a fraction of the size of a
combustion engine and so
oftentimes we can fit the
motor in a single speed reduction
gearbox in the same space where the
original transmission was and the entire
engine bay becomes available for us to
put batteries and other components in it
we're also looking to make sure that
we're not putting stresses on the
chassis in areas that it wasn't designed
to take
if you just put the electric motor in
the engine bay and you put batteries in
the trunk you're going to end up an
incredibly unbalanced and possibly
dangerous car
so we try to distribute the weight of
the batteries
throughout the chassis our goal is to
retain the performance and the
feel of this car
these cars were designed
50 years ago very precisely by hundreds
if not thousands of engineers who are
trying to create a certain drive we want
to respect that as much as possible
then we are wiring everything together
wiring up a car is kind of in two phases
there's the high voltage wiring that
powers the motor and connects the
battery pack to the system
and that is relatively simple and
straightforward but there's another set
of wiring that happens in these cars
that we call vehicle control wiring
we want this car to be driven and
enjoyed the same way that it's always
been with the beautiful gauges that were
designed in the 60s with the
analog sweeping
needles and things like that
nobody's buying this
wanting a tesla right they
don't want to get into a classic car and
have a giant ipad on their
dashboard
there's so many components that we
installed so many different things that
have to come together and it's kind of
like we put an orchestra together for
the first time and
that those first drives when you get in
the car
[Music]
tap your little
conductor's wand on the thing and say
okay let's do this let's try this piece
from the start
[Music]
you go out on a drive and
you know what the drummer is you know
pushing pushing a little too hard and
the
uh you know the trumpets are just just
not quite hitting that high note you
hear all those things you take it all in
and you think okay there's something
here we're going to be able to get there
but we got to work on these things
we are out there putting hundreds if not
thousands of miles on the car making
sure that it responds the way that it
should intuitively drives the way you
would expect it to we're able to
manipulate torque curves and all sorts
of inputs and controls we can change the
way that the motor reacts to the
throttle position if you will we take
this time to tune
each section of this orchestra and bring
it all together so that when you get in
and you drive it it is a
flawless performance one that makes
people
smile
and cry
and engages them in a way that they have
never
driven before and that's the goal
we often get the question well how much
does this cost and the reality is
it depends a lot on the car that we're
that we're starting with uh the size of
the car the condition of the car and the
performance and range requirements of of
the owner so
it is a pretty large range but it can be
anywhere from fifty thousand dollars to
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
[Music]
in terms of moving the needle on climate
change transportation is critical and
arguably the lowest hanging fruit this
is a huge swath of greenhouse gas
emissions and electrifying these
vehicles is kind of one of the easiest
and fastest ways
the new eb market last year in the world
was about seven million vehicles that's
about 10
of the global
sales both globally and in the us
the ev market more than doubled last
year the adoption curve is steepening
quite a bit faster than most people even
expected
by most people i would include auto
executives in that ford motor for
example is rushing to make electric
vehicles as fast as it can
mr president this sucker's quick
there will always be people driving
their gasoline cars even 50 years from
now maybe more at that point it'll it'll
be such a novelty but
i think the shift is going to happen
quickly the adoption is going to be
fast and faster than we realized
the implications of maintenance on a
classic car with a 60 year old
drivetrain are significant right it's a
diminishing
population of people who are able to do
that and the parts are hard to get and
the knowledge is hard to come by and
there's something
that feels a little bit like
that's coming to an end and i think that
for people to
put in place a you know modern electric
drive drain gives them the confidence in
the future gives them the you know the
feeling that they can
no longer
you know worry about that
[Music]
when you go and you look at the beauty
and the simplicity involved in an
electric motor i mean
there's only two parts where
the moving parts touch one another it's
in on the bearings right and that's it
and everything just spins with
electromagnetism
there's no real comparison between
that technology and
what we used to use to you know to
propel cars so i don't know i think that
that is the future
[Music]
you